สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาตี้อ่า
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนอ่า
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันเจอกันอีกแล้วในช่อง
comprehensible  Thai ครับเย้
อ่าโอเคเรามาเจอกันวันนี้เดี๋ยวนะวันอะไร
คะครูอาติวันนี้ที่เราเจอกันเราก็ต้องเจอ
กันทุกวันจันทร์สิครับทุกวันจันทร์นะคะ
ใช่วันจันทร์แต่ไม่รู้ว่าไม่รู้ว่าคลิป
เนี้ยไปโพสต์วันไหนนะกที่ี้ก็ไม่รู้
เหมือนกันแต่วันที่เราวันที่เราคุยกัน
เนี่ยเป็นวันจันทร์แล้วเปลี่ยนเป็นวัน
อื่นะไม่
เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนได้นะครับเปลี่ยนได้นะครับ
โอเคแต่วันนี้วันจันทร์อยู่นะครับก็ก็เลย
วันจันทร์อืวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์วันที่ 6 ครับวันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนนี้เดือนอ่อ
กุมภาพันธ์เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ใช่ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2566 ครับอ่า
2566 ใช่เป็นยังไงเดือนที่ 2 แล้วเหรอคะ
ใช่เดือนที่ 2 แล้วนะ
หู
2566 เดือนที่ 2 แล้วโอใชเร็วใช่มั้ย
ครับเร็วมากนะคะ
อ่าโอเคแล้วตอนนี้๊ค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ 2023
ครับ
2023 อ่าตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะอ่าตอนนี้ครู
อตี้ย้ายไปเป็นตอนบ่ายบ้างครับนักเรียนจะ
ได้รู้จักเวลาตอนบ่ายบ้างอ่าค่ะ 14 น 2 น
ตึ๊ดๆๆตึ๊ดๆ 25 นาทีครับอ่าออกครูเอ๋นับ
ผิด
225 นทอ่าเป็นตอนบ่ายนะอ่า 14 น 25 น
ครับค่ะออ
ครูอตี้คะวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีคำถามอ่ามีคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับอะไรครับค่ะคลิปนี้เราจะเป็นคุย
กันนะคะคุยกันแบเอเบเบอๆมยคะภาพครูเอต้อง
ไม่นิ่งๆใช่มยห้าม
ขยับขยับได้ครับขยับแล้วอยู่นิ่ง
ๆคือคือตอนบ่ายแต่แสงไม่พอนะ
อืปวดหัวครับโอเคครูเอ๋มีคำถามครูอัคำถาม
ว่าอะไรครับปกติครูอัเนี่ยชอบไปทำบุญมั้ย
คะอ่าคูตี้ก็ทำบุญบ้างนิดหน่อยครับไม่ได้
ทำเป็นประจำแต่ทำครับทำจริงๆครูเอ๋ควรจะ
ถามครูอาตี้ก่อนว่าูครูอาตี้น่ะศาสนาพุทธ
มยคะอ่าใช่ๆๆอ่าคูตี้เป็นคนไทยคนไทยส่วน
ใหญ่อ่าคนไทยส่วนใหญ่นับถือศาสนาพุทธค่ะ
ส่วนใหญ่นะคะศาสนาพุทธใช่ 2 ก็อาจจะ
มุสลิมเนาะอ่าใช่ครับมีมุสลิมมีคริสต์
บ้างแล้วคริสตแล้วก็พราหมณ์ฮินดูบ้างนะคะ
ใช่ใช่ครับงั้นเนี่ยก็ครูอาตี้ก็นับถือ
ศาสนาพุทธครับครูเอ๋ก็นับถือศาสนาพุทธนะ
คะอือศาสนาพุทธเราก็จะไปทำบุญใช่ทำบุญไป
ทำบุญน่ะอ่าคนไทยก็ชอบไปทำบุญนะคะออ
ทำไมถึงไปทำบุญอโอเคครูเอ๋ต่อเลยครับอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋ใช่มั้ยทำไมถึงไปทำบุญใช่มั้ยคะค่ะ
เอ่อเอาครูเอก่ะค่ะไปทำบุญทำไมครับบางค์
ก่อนแล้วกันเอาแบบ beginner นะแบบ
beginner บางคนสงสัยลูกคูตี้ก็สงสัย
เหมือนกันถามพ่อๆทำไมพ่อต้องไปทำ
บุญคือคือเอาแบบครูเออ๋หเอาแบบคนไทยต้อง
ถามครูอาตี้ก่อนอ่าเอาแบบคนไทยทั่วไปครับ
ว่าทำไมแบบคนไทยนะคะนักเรียนเพราะถ้าเอา
แบบครูเอ๋นักเรียนต้องฟังแอดวานได้ก่อน
นะกูอธิบายเยอะเหรอเอาอธิบายง่ายๆอ่าที่
เด็กๆเข้าใจได้นะ
อ
ก็เออเอาแบบคนไทยใช่มั้นักเรียนบอกเอ๊ะ
อะไรครูเอ๋คือแบบคนไทยน่ะก็คือเราก็เชื่อ
ว่าทำบุญน่ะเป็นการทำดีๆอืนะคะดีเรามี
อาหารแล้วก็เอาไปวัดให้กับพระใช่มั้ยคะมี
อาหารมีของกินน่ะค่ะนักเรียนอือาหารแล้ว
ก็ไปอ่าทำบุญก็คือมีอาหารหรืออย่างอื่นก็
ได้นะคะแล้วก็ไปที่วัดอฮะให้กับพระจริงๆ
ทำบุญมีหลายๆแบบนะคะหลายๆแบบแต่ว่าเราเอา
วันนี้เราพูดถึงทำบุญที่วัดก่อนเนาะอ่า
วันนี้เราจะคุยกันเรื่องทำบุญที่วัดก่อน
ที่ที่วัดนะคะที่วัดมีทำบุญที่วัดทำบุญ
ไม่ไม่ไม่ต้องไปวัดก็ทำบุญได้อแต่วัน
เนี้ยทำบุญแบบไปวัดนะคะไปวัดพอเรามีอาหาร
มีอะไรที่ไปทำบุญแล้วเนี่ยก็บางคนก็เชื่อ
ว่าอาหารที่เราให้พระแล้วพระฉันอือฮึนะคะ
พระฉันคือกินน่ะค่ะนักเรียนอ๋ออาฉันก็คือ
การกินโอเคใช่แล้วอาอันเนี้ยก็ก็เหมือน
กับ
เอ่อส่ง
ไปให้กับคุณพ่อคุณแม่คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตา
คุณยายคุณทวดใครก็ได้ที่เรารักครับแล้วก็
เสียชีวิตแล้ว
อ๋ออหมายถึงการที่การที่เราเอาอาหารที่
ที่ดีๆอาหารที่เราชอบอาหารที่เอ่อคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่คุณตาคุณยายคนที่ตายไปแล้วชอบเนี่ย
เอาไปให้พระให้พระฉันอ่าครูอาตี้วาดวาด
รูปก่อนได้มั้ยคะวาดรูปครูอาตี้แล้วก็พ่อ
แม่อ่าเดี๋ยวนะเอเดี๋ยวนักเรียนบางคนไม่
เคยไปฟังคลิปที่พ่อแม่พี่น้องอ่าจะงงกลัว
จะงงใช่มั้ยครับอ่ามีพ่ออ่ามีแม่นะครับ
อ่าอ่าแล้วก็แต่งงานการมีลูกเอออ่ามีมี
ลูกโอเคแต่งงานกันมีลูกตัวเล็กๆอ่ะพอลูก
โตๆลูกแต่งงานอ่าลูกแต่งงานอีกโอเคอืแล้ว
ก็มีมีหลานอ่ามีลูกอีกค่ะอ่ามีหลานถ้า
เป็นโอเคครับอ่ะทีนี้เเด็กคนคนคนเล็กเ่ะ
อ่ะอ่ะให้ชื่อ 1 ก็ได้อ่ะ 1 คนนี้คนนี้
ครับ 1 เนี่ยก็จะมีคุณพ่อคุณแม่อ่าใช่
ครับคนนี้เป็นคุณพ่อคุณแแล้วก็คุณคุณแล้ว
พ่อแม่ก็มีพ่อแม่อีกอ่าพ่อแม่ของพ่อแม่
ตันนี้ก็จะเรียกเป็นอ่ะถ้าเป็นของพ่อใช่
มั้ยครับก็เป็นคุณ
ปู่คุณปู่ใช่มั้ยใช่คุณปู่แล้วก็เป็นคุณ
ย่าคุณย่าถ้าเป็นพ่อแม่ของแม่วาดอีก 2 คน
เนาะอ่าถ้าเป็นพ่อแม่ของแม่ใช่มั้ยครับ
อ่าพ่อแม่ของของ
แม่โอเคอ่าเป็นอันนี้เป็นเลเวลเดียวกัน
ใช่มั้ยครับอ่าอยู่ระดับเดียวกัน
โอเคพ่อแม่ของแม่ก็จะเป็นคุณตากับคุณยายค
ไหนคุณตาคะกับคุณยายคนนี้ก็จะเป็นคุณตา
ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงก็จะเป็นคุณยายเพราะว่า
เป็นแม่ของแม่อือฮึค่ะบางทีเราโตขึ้นมา
คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายน่ะ
ตายแล้วนะคะหรือเสียชีวิตจะพูดตายโอเค
เสียชีวิตโอเคอือฮึงั้นเนี่ยเราก็คิดถึง
อืเราก็ไม่รู้เอ๊ะอาหารไปยังไงอ่าทำยังไง
หิวข้าวมั้ยอ๋อคุณปู่คุณย่าแข็งแรงดีมั้ย
อย่างเงี้ยอครับก็ก็เป็นความเชื่อของคน
ไทยว่าทำบุญเนี่ยบุญอันเนี้ยจะ
ส่งส่งไปให้คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายได้มี
อาหารกินดีๆใช่มั้ยคะ
อาฮะแล้วก็ไม่ใช่ส่งให้คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตา
คุณยายอย่างเดียวอ่าโอส่งให้ใครได้อีกตัว
เราด้วยอ๋อส่งให้ตัวเราได้ด้วยเหรอครับ
เ้ามีมีล่าสุดบอกให้ตัวเองได้ด้วยนะออื
ใช่ๆๆให้ตัวเองให้ตัวเองได้แต่แต่ไม่ใช่
ได้ตอนนี้นะคะไม่ได้ตอนนี้เป็นการเก็บตอ
ตายไปแล้วเก็บสะสมเอาไว้เก็บเอาไว้ก่อนนะ
ครับค่ะแต่แต่ว่าเอ่อบางคนก็บอกว่าออให้
คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยาย
ให้ให้ใครก็ได้ที่ตายแล้วอ๋อให้เอ่อคน
อื่นๆนะครับที่เป็นคนที่เรารู้จักคนที่
เราไม่รู้จักได้เหมือนกันให้ได้นะครับให้
ได้นะให้ได้จริงๆทำบุญก็เป็นการฝึกกันให้
ล่ะค่ะให้นะรู้จักการให้นะคะอใช่ครับอ่า
ทำให้เราให้อ๋อก็เป็นการเพราะฉะนั้นการทำ
บุญก็คือจะเ่อเป็นการเกี่ยวกับการให้ให้
แล้วทำให้เรามีความสุขมีความสุขใจมีความ
สุขที่ได้ให้ใช่โอเคนะคะอืแต่แต่ว่าบางคน
เ้าก็เชื่อว่าทำบุญแล้วมีโชคดีโชคดีก็จะ
ไปที่คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายอือหรือใคร
ก็ได้ที่เราให้นะคะที่ตายไปแล้วนะคะก็เลย
ต้องทำบุญทำบุญอ่าคนไทยก็เลยไปทำบุญกันนะ
ใช่นะคะก็เลยไปทำบุญกันที่วัดนะคะที่วัด
อ่าวันนี้เราจะพูดเกี่ยวกับทำบุญที่วัด
ใช่มั้ยครับใช่ค่ะเราจะไปทำบุญที่วัดกัน
ค่ะนักเรียนโอเอ่าวัดมีลักษณะเป็นแบบไหน
ถ้าบางคนยังไม่รู้จักเดี๋ยวครูติเปิดรูป
วัดให้ดูก่อนครับได้ค่ะอ่านี่ครับนี่คือ
วัดเป็นวัดไทยนะอรุณวัดไทยออทำไมครูเอ๋
รู้ว่าวัดอรุณเจดีย์เจดีย์ใช่เพราะที่วัด
อรุณมีเจดีย์ที่เป็นเอ่อลักษณะแบบนี้เป็น
ลักษณะเฉพาะของที่วัดอุเฉพาะเลยอืใช่ครับ
แล้วก็ก้อนหินก้อนนั้นนะคะครูเอ๋เคยไป
แล้วครูเอ๋จำได้ใช่มั้ยไปบ่อยหลายครั้งจำ
ได้อ๋อก้อนไหนครับก้อนเนี้ยก้อนไม่อีกอี
อีกเนี้ยตรงวก้อนนี้ใช่มอ๋อโอเคอ่าเราก็
ไปทำบุญกันที่วัดคนไทยนะครับสวนใหจริงๆ
วัดวัดไหนก็ได้นะคะที่มีพระนะคะออือจะวัด
เล็กๆวัดใหญ่ๆได้หมดค่ะอ่าครับงั้นก็เรา
ก็จะไปที่วัดเแล้วอ๋ออ่านี่ก็เป็นวัดอีก
วัดนึงเหมือนกันค่ะอันนี้วัดสุทัศนะคะอ๋อ
ครับอ่าเมื่อกี้ครูเอ๋อ๋อครูเอ๋จะบอกว่า
คือถ้าเราไปทำบุญที่วัดเนี่ยเนี่ยครับเรา
ก็จะได้เห็นอะไรสวยๆอืมอ่าเพราะว่าวัด
เนี่ยสวยครับัอ่าวัดไทยมีสวยๆส่วนใหญ่วัด
ไทยก็จะสวยใช่แล้วคนไปที่วัดเวลาตั้งใจไป
ทำบุญน่ะนะคะเค้าก็จะบางทีเ้าก็จะแต่งตัว
สวยๆหรือบางทีแต่งตัวออธรรมดาแต่เขาจะ
ยิ้มอ่านะยิ้มคือบางคนก็สวยเลยแต่งหน้าทำ
ผมสวยแต่บางบางคนก็คือจะเรียบร้อยใช่มั้
คือคือเอชอบที่สุดเวลาไปทำบุญที่วัดคือจะ
จะจะแต่งตัวสวยหรือไม่สวยไม่เป็นไรแต่
ส่วนใหญ่จะยิ้มอ่าอ่าจะยิ้มนะคะครูเอ๋ชอบ
ตรงนี้ก็เลยชอบไปที่วัดเพราะว่าจะไปเห็น
คนยิ้มเยอะอือฮึอ่าเพราะว่าคนทำบุญก็จะมี
ความสุขอ่าการทำบุญก็จะทำให้เรามีความสุข
เพราะว่าคิดว่าเ่อการทำความดีเราก็มีความ
สุขจากการให้จากการทำบุญให้กับพระเราก็จะ
มีความสุขไปด้วยพอเรามีความสุขเราก็ยิ้ม
ยิ้มใช่มยิ้มทีนี้เนี่ยคือหรือบางคนแบบ
โอ้ปวดหัวมีปัญหาแต่พอไปวัดปั๊บเฮ้อรู้
สึกสบายใจก็ยิ้มนะคะก็อย่างอย่างในรูป
เนี่ยอ่ามองเข้าไปเราจะเห็นพระอันนี้เป็น
โบสถ์นะคะเรียกว่าโบสถ์ออใช่ตรงนี้เป็น
โบสถ์นะคะข้างในโบสถ์ใช่มยครูเอบอกว่าอง
เข้าไปข้างในข้างในโบสถ์อยู่ในนี้ครับใน
นี้ก็จะมีพระพุทธรูปนะคะอ๋ออาฮะพระ
พุทธรูปองค์อาจจะบางทีองค์เล็กๆแต่บางที
ก็องค์โตๆใหญ่ๆอ่าที่อยู่ข้างในโบสถ์น่ะ
ครับอ่อเรียกว่าพระอะไรคะครูอาติอ่าที่
อยู่ข้างในโบสถ์เอ่อพระที่องค์ที่ใหญ่ที่
สุดก็เรียกว่าพระประธานอ่าพระประธานนะคะ
มีรูปมั้ยครูเออ๋มีรูปใช่มั้ยมีมีอีกรูป
นึงอ่านี่อ๋ออันนี้ใช่มั้ยครับนี่อยู่
ข้างในอยู่ข้างในโบสถ์นะครับค่ะเป็นพระ
ประธานแต่รูปที่อยู่ข้างหลังคูอาตี้อัน
นั้นไม่ใช่พระประธานเนาะอ๋ออันนี้อยู่
ข้างนอกไม่ได้อยู่ในโบสถ์ใช่อาฮะก็เป็น
พระพระข้างนอกไม่ใช่เป็นพระพุทธรูปแต่ไม่
พูดว่าพระประธานนะคะพระประธานจะมีเอ่อ
เป็นองค์ที่ใหญ่ที่สุดสำคัญที่สุดอ่าส่วน
ใหญ่จะอยู่ในโบสถ์ส่วนใหญ่จะอยู่ในโบสถ์
อือฮึต้องอยู่ในโบสถ์เลยค่ะอ่ะต้องอยู่ใน
โบสถ์ใช่มั้ยครับกติเคยเห็นเป็นพระองค์
ใหญ่ๆเป็นพระประธานอยู่ข้างนอันนั้นไม่
เรียกไม่เรียกพระประธานไม่เรียกพระประธาน
ข้างนอกไม่เรียกพระประธานพระประธานคือใน
โบสถ์นะคะในโบถ์โอเค 100% ในโบสถ์ค่ะอ๋อ
โอเคอยู่ในโบสถ์แลองค์ที่ใหญ่ที่สุดด้วย
เป็นประธานใช่มั้ยครับค่ะคืออาจจะถ้าถ้า
มีพระเยอะๆก็ต้องก็อาจจะองค์ใหญ่ที่สุด
หรือหรือองค์ที่อยู่สูงที่สุดบางวัดอาจจะ
มีองค์เล็กๆแต่ว่าอยู่ข้างบนสูงก็เป็นพระ
ประธานได้นะคะอืครับทีนี้ก็นี่ไงเวลาเรา
ไปเราไปที่วัดน่ะครับเราจะได้เห็นพระ
ประธานซึ่งพระประธานเนี่ยสวยอือฮึแล้วก็
ยิ้มเวลามองเนี่ยรู้สึกใจดีอ่ามีความสุข
อ่าใช่มองมองหน้าพระประธานแล้วเฮ้อสบายใจ
อคนไทยนะคนไทยสบายใจครับแล้วก็รู้สึกว่า
สงบด้วยใช่มั้ยครับสงบก็คือเพราะเวลาอยู่
ในโบสถ์เนี่ยเราทุกคนก็จะเอ่อเ่อมีอาการ
เ่อเงียบๆนะครับนิ่งๆอ่าแล้วก็พูดน้อยๆ
อ่ะหรือไม่พูดกันอืต้องสงบอยู่ในความสงบ
อยู่ในโบสถ์เอเสียงดังไม่ได้เหมือนคล้ายๆ
กับอยู่ในห้องสมุดครับแต่ในบทก็จะ
เอ่อเอ่อร่มพูดเนใช่ไม่พูดกว่าเงียบกว่า
นะครับเงียบนะแต่ว่าถ้าข้างนอกข้างนอกก็
อาจจะพูดได้นะคะเรียกว่าศาลาทีนี้พอไปใช่
มั้ยคะเราไปอ่ะตอนนี้นักเรียนรู้แล้วว่า
มีโบสถ์มีพระประทานแล้วก็มีพระที่เป็นคน
ผู้ชายเรียกว่าพระสงฆ์นะคะทีนี้เราไปทำ
บุญที่วัดเนี่ยก็จะมี 2 แบบเหมือนกันครับ
แบบแบบแบบแบบที่ 1 เลยคือไม่มีเวลาไปวัด
ไหว้พระแล้วก็มีเงินแล้วก็หยอดตู้มีตู้
อ๋อแบบนี้ก็เรียกว่าทำบุญเหมือนกันอ่าอัน
นี้เดี๋ยวทำบุญแบบที่ 1 แบบที่เวลาน้อย
ใช่มั้ยแบบที่เวลาน้อยไปวัดไหว้พระแล้วก็
เ่อทำบุญด้วยวิธีนี้ครับอ่าหยอดตู้อ่า
หยอดตู้นะครับอ่าหยอดตู้คืออะไรครับหยอด
ตู้ก็คือการบริจาคบริจาคคือการให้ให้ชนิด
นึงแต่ไม่ได้ให้อาหารอ่าไม่ได้ให้อาหาร
ให้เป็นอะไรครับให้เป็นเงินค่ะอ่าให้เป็น
เงินอุแต่เ้าไม่เรียกเงินเนาะเงอ่าอ่ามี
คำสำหรับอ่อสำหรับเ่อการถวายเงินให้พระ
อ่ามีเราเรียกใช้คำว่าอะไรครับอ่าปัจจัย
ปัจอครับอือ่าถวายถวายถวายคือให้นะคะให้
อะไรจริงๆคือให้เงิน
แต่ว่าไม่พูดว่าให้เงินพูดว่าถวายปัจจัย
นะคะอันนี้อาจจะอเป็นค่าน้ำค่าไฟใช่มั้ย
คะเพราะว่าที่วัดก็ต้องใช้น้ำล้างจานพระ
ก็ต้องอาบน้ำก็ต้องจ่ายเงินสำหรับค่าน้ำ
อืใช่มั้คก็ก็อันนี้ก็อาจจะสำหรับเ่อค่า
น้ำหรือค่าไฟเพราะว่าพระต้องอ่านหนังสือ
ก็ต้องเปิดไฟเหมือนคุณใช่อ่าเวลาเปิดไฟไฟ
เอ่าเปิดไฟก็ต้องใช้ไฟฟ้าใช้ไฟฟ้าก็ต้อง
ใช้เงินซื้อไฟฟ้าก็เอาเงินจากตรงเยครับ
เอาเอาเงินที่ที่เราทำบุญไปนี่แหละไปอ่า
อืก็ไปจ่ายค่าน้ำค่าไฟนะคะหรือว่าบางที
พระไม่สบายครับก็ก็เอาไปสำหรับพระไม่สบาย
หรือพระต้องเรียนหนังสือือนะคะต้องเรียน
ก็ไปซื้อกระดาษเนาะบางทีก็ซื้อซื้อ
หนังสือซื้อกระดาษปากกาดินสอมาใช้อค่ะ
ซื้อกระดาษซื้อปากกาอืคะนะคะงั้นน่ะเราก็
ไม่ต้องเป็นอาหารก็ได้มีเวลานิดหน่อยออ
อันนี้ค่าน้ำค่าไฟนะอันนี้ค่าพระเรียน
หนังสืออันนะอันนี้สำหรับวัดนะอครับอือฮึ
ก็เป็นการทำบุญแบบเอ่อรีบๆนะครับใช้เวลา
น้อยได้เหมือนกันเป็นการทำบุญแบบนึงนะคะ
แต่ก็ไปที่วัดนะคะใช่ต้องไปที่วัดครับอือ
ฮึอ่ะแล้วถ้าไปที่วัดแบบมีเวลาเยอะลคะครู
อาติอ๋อถ้ามีเวลาเยอะเอ่อเอ่อเราก็จะไปมี
อาหารอ่าใช้อ่าอาหารนะครับทำบุญด้วยอาหาร
แต่ถ้าทำบุญด้วยอาหารเนี่ยต้องไปตอนไหน
ครับคอ๋ออ่าพระจะฉันประมาณ 8:00 นก็
ประมาณ 7:00 นอือฮึนะฮะตอนเช้า 7  7:00 น
หรือว่าบางวัดพระฉัน 11:00 นอ่ามีครับบาง
วัด
เอ่อบางวัดพระจะฉันถ้าพระฉัน 1 ครั้งนะ
ครับพระก็จะฉันตอนเอ่อตอน 11:00 นใช่มั้ย
ครับค่ะอ่าหรือว่าถ้าฉัน 2 ครั้งก็จะฉัน
ตอนเช้า 7 นแล้วก็ 11:00 น 2 รอบใช่งั้น
เนี่ยเราก็ต้องต้องไปวัดแล้วแต่ว่าเราง
เวลาตอนเช้าหรือว่าไปไปตอน 11:00 นก่อน
11:00 นนะคะต้องก่อนนะคะนักเรียน 11:00
นเรียกว่าเพนนะคะต้องก่อน 11:00 นอือค่ะ
ครูอันตี้มีรูปใช่มั้ยคะเวลาเราจะไปวัด
เนี่ยอ่าครับเราจะต้องเตรียมอ่ะอันที่ 1
เลยค่ะดอกไม้ธูปเทียนดอกไม้ธูปเทียนเป็น
แบบนี้ครับนี่ครับครับเลือกได้เลยนะคะอ่า
มีมีดอกอะไรบ้างคะอ่าดอกนี้ดอกอันแรกนี้
ชื่อว่าดอกดาวเรืองครับค่าดาวเรืองอ่า
แล้วก็มี 2 อันที่ 2 อ่าอันนี้นักเรียน
ต้องรู้จักแน่ๆเลยนะครับมีเยอะนะครับอัน
นี้ดอกบัวดอกบัวนะคะอันที่ 3 อันที่ 3
โทรศัพท์ให้ด้วยเป็นดอกกล้วยไม้ครับอ
เดี๋ยวแล้วเอ๋ครูเอ๋เอียงทำไมไม่ได้ครู
เอ๋ไม่ต้องเอียงครู
โอเคอ่าอันโดยส่วนใหญ่นะคะแต่ว่าจริงๆดอก
ไม้อะไรก็ได้นะคะใช่ถ้าที่บ้านมีดอกไม้ก็
เก็บดอกไม้ที่บ้านไปได้นะครับใช่ดอกไม้
อะไรก็ได้นะคะแต่แต่ว่าที่ที่เราจะเห็น
ส่วนใหญ่เขาก็จะใช้ดอกดาวเรืองใช่ครับดอก
บัวนะคะแล้วก็ดอกกล้วยไม้ครับที่มีขายตาม
ท้องที่ตลาดจะมีขายนะครับซื้อได้ง่ายง
ส่วนสีสีเขียวเป็นเรียกว่าอะไรคะสีเขียวๆ
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยครับอ่าอันนี้เรียก
เป็นเป็นใบไม้ชนิดนึงที่คนไทยเอ่อนิยมนะ
ครับปลูกไว้ที่บ้านเพราะมีกลิ่นหอมเรา
เรียกว่าใบเตยครับอืใบเตยนะคะใช่ที่บ้าน
คนไทยจะมีมากๆแล้วบ้านครูเอ๋ก็มีบ้านครู
อาตี้มีมั้ยคะอบ้านครูอาตี้ไม่มีใบเตยออ
ไม่ได้ปลูกคือคือมีคนไทยหลายๆคนต่าง
จังหวัดเนี่ยนะคะคนต่างจังหวัดเนี่ยเมื่อ
กี้ครูอาตี้บอกว่านิยมนิยมก็คือชอบแล้วก็
จะปลูกจะมีที่บ้านนะคะบ้านครูเอ๋ที่ที่
ที่ชลบุรีมีที่กรุงเทพฯมีใบเตยนะคะเพราะ
ว่าหอมนะคะอแล้วก็อันไหนเป็นธูปคะอ่าอัน
นี้เป็นธูปครับธูปแล้วก็เทียน่เทียนเทียน
ก็จะเป็นอ่ะกูตี้ให้ดูอันใหญ่นนี่เทียน
นี่นัแล้วก็ธูปแล้วก็ธูปนะครับไปพร้อมกับ
ดอกไม้ครูอาตี้ตรงขาวๆอ่ะใกล้ๆธูปกับ
เทียนเห็นมั้ยคะที่เป็นกระดาษอ่ะอ๋อตรง
นี้ใช่มั้ยครับอ่า
อ่าเป็นอะไรรู้มั้ยคะอ่าอันนี้เป็นทองอ่า
เป็นทองคำครับทองเแต่ว่าเป็นทองคำเปลวนะ
ครับเป็นทองคำเปลวมีทองคำอยู่ข้างในอ่าก็
นักเียเอ๊อะไรคือทองคำครูครูอตี้ในนั้นจะ
มีรูปกลมๆรูกนิมิตรูกนิมิตเดี๋ยวนะครับ
อ่าครูอตี้หารูกนิมิตที่มีทองคำอยู่ใช่
มั้ยครับโอเคอ่ะนี่นี่อ่านี่คือทองคำที่
อยู่ในกระดาษนะครับใช่อที่อยู่ในกระดาษจะ
มีเป็นแผ่นเล็กๆสี่เหลี่ยมแบบนี้อยู่ใน
กระดาษเมื่อกี้ที่กับดอกไม้อือฮึอันนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะครูอาตี้ทองคำเลวอ่าเเ้า
แปะที่ไหนคะอ๋อแปะลงไปบนลูกนิมิตครับลูก
นี้ิอ่าอ่าลูลูกนิมิตกลมๆอ่าลูกนิมิตทำมา
จากหินนะครับทำมาจากหินนอ่าทำหินเนาก็
เดี๋ยวเขาก็จะขุดขุดดินแล้วก็ฝังที่วัดนะ
คะใช่อ่าฝังรอบๆโบสถ์ค่ะอ่ารอบๆโบสถ์จะ
ฝังลูกนิมิตอันนี้เอาไว้นะครับค่ะอือโอเค
อ่ะมีดอกไม้มีธูปเทียนะคะอ่าในวัดก็มีลูก
นิมิตมีพระประธานต้องมีอาหารด้วยใช่มั้ยอ
อ่าใช่ครับมีอาหารครับอาหารเนี่ยนักเรียน
จะมี 2 ชนิดนะคะครับก็จะมีอาหาร
คาวอาหารคาวอนี้เป็นอาหารข้าว
อ่าอันนี้อันนี้เป็นอาหารพระพุอันนี้มั้ย
อาหารพระพุทธอาหารพระ
พุทธเวลาไปที่วัดเรามี
อาหารขาว
โอเคอาหารคาวในรูปก็จะมีกุ้งอือะไรกุ้งเอ
มีกุ้งครับกุ้งหมึกอืหมึกอยู่นี่ครับนี่
แล้วก็ปลาปลาอยู่นี่ครับนักเรียนจะดู
สังเกตว่าทุกอย่างจะหั่นเอาไว้กุ้งก็จะมี
มีเปลือกเแกะอ๋อแกะออกหมดเลยครับผมเพราะ
ว่าเราจะเราจะเอากุ้งแบบกุ้งมาแล้วย่าง
แล้วก็ไปถวายพระแล้วก็พระต้องแกะเองเนี่ย
ได้มั้ยอ่าถ้าให้พระแกะเองครูอตี้คิดว่า
น่าจะไม่ได้ครับเพราะว่าพระต้องเ่อมีเวลา
ไม่มากในการฉัอาหารนะครับใช่แล้วพระต้อง
ต้องเรียบร้อยเวลาที่ฉันอาหารฉะนั้นเนี่ย
นักเรียนจะเอากุ้งไปแล้วให้พระมานั่งแกะ
อย่างเงี้ยไม่ได้นะคะต้องเอ่อควรจะเรา
ต้องบอกควรจะอือควรจะแกะไปให้พระเลยนะคะ
อ่าเพื่อให้พระฉันได้ง่ายที่สุดนะครับใช่
ครับอันนี้เป็นอาหารคาวอ่ะอาหารหวานอ้าว
มีอาหารหวานด้วยใช่มั้ยครับใช่อาหารหวาน
โอใช่อันนี้มั้ยูแบบนี้ไม่ได้นะคะเมื่อ
กี้ไม่ได้กู
อติแบบแบบเมื่อกี้เป็นอาหารคาวที่เอาไป
วัดแล้วพระต้องแกะปูอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้ไม่
ได้อันไหนอันไหนอันนี้ใช่มั้ยอ๋อไปทั้ง
ตัวแบบนี้ไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่
ได้เอ้อพระจะแกะแล้วดูดอันนี้มันคุณครู
อาตี้กับครูเออ๋โอเคค่ะนักเรียนจะไปถวาย
อาหารน่ะให้พระโดยที่ปูเป็นตัวๆแบบเนี้ย
ไม่ได้นะคะต้องแกะเอาไปให้เรียบร้อยนะคะ
อ่ะอาหารหวานมีอหารหวานหาคูตี้คลิกแล้ว
มันมาอันนี้รูปนี้มันขึ้นมาได้ยังไง
เดี๋ยวนะอันนี้ใช่มั้ยครับที่ครูเอ๋หมาย
ถึงโอเคใช่คือคืออาหารหวานบางทีคนไทยบาง
ทีทำไปเป็นหม้อเลยนะอ่าแล้วเาก็จะไปจัด
แบ่งออันนี้เรียกว่าทอเอ้ยไม่ใช่เม็ดขนุน
อันนี้เม็ดขนุนอ่าอาหารหวานก็คือขนมหวาน
นั่นเองนะบางครั้งนักเรียนจะได้ยินคนไทย
เรียกขนมขนมขนมก็คืออาหารหวานครับใช่ก็
คือก็คือเค้กก็ได้คุกกี้ก็ได้นะคะแต่ว่า
เวลาเราไปเราเอาอาหารไปถวายพระก็จะมีของ
คาวแล้วก็ของหวานถ้าไม่มีของหวานก็ต้องมี
ผลไม้ครับอ่าเป็นของหวานผลไม้อ่าของหวาน
อะไรก็ได้นะครับอาจะเป็นขนมนี้ขนมอะไรก็
ได้ที่มีนะครับที่เราคิดว่าอันนี้จะเป็น
ขนมใส่ไส้อ่าครับผมผลไม้ใช่มั้ยผลไม้ใช่
ผลไม้ผลไม้ก็ต้องหั่นเป็นชิ้นๆนะคะใช่
ครับชิ้นไปให้เรียบร้อยเอ่อถ้าถ้าเวลาที่
เราจะมีขนมอ้าเดี๋ยวก่อนมีเมื่อกี้ที่ครู
อาตี้คิกออาหารที่เป็นถาดอ๋ออาหารที่เป็น
ถาดใช่มั้ยครับอันนี้อันนี้เ่าเวลาที่เรา
จะถวายพระอันนี้เป็นอาหารพระพุทธอ๋อก็คือ
ถวายพระพุทธรูปใช่มั้ยครับนะเป็นตัวแทน
พระพุทธรูปก็เป็นตัวแทนของพระพุทธเจ้าใช
ใช่นักเรียนก็จะสงสัยเอ๊ะพระพุทธรูปกิน
ได้
เหรออเราก็ถวายเป็นเอ่อเป็นเป็นประเพณี
เนาะอ่าเป็นประเพณีครับผมอือฮึก็ต้องถวาย
มีเรามีอะไรที่ให้พระส
เราก็จัดเป็นชุดเล็กๆแล้วก็อ่าเป็นอาหาร
ของพระพุทธนะคะครับพระพุทธรูปหรือพระ
พุทธเจ้านะ
คะแล้วก็มีเอ่ออาหารของพระสงฆ์ก็จะจาน
ใหญ่หน่อยใช่ครับจานใหญ่นิดนึงอือฮึนะฮะอ
อันนี้ก็เป็นของหวานที่จะถวายพของหวานอ่ะ
นี่ผลไม้กาตี้จำผลไม้ได้จำใช่ขนมใี้
เราจะทำอะไรที่จะไปถวายพระ
เอออาหารอะไรที่เราจะเอาไปทำบุญน่ะ
อ๋อออาหารอะไรที่จะเอาไปทำบุญก็อาหารที่
เราชอบมั้ยเออใช่มั้ยอาหารที่เราชอบหรือ
อาหารที่เราคิดว่าคิดว่าดีที่สุดแล้วก็
เ่อพระก็น่าจะชอบหรือหรือรเมื่อกี้ที่เรา
พูดกันตอนแรกเราพูดว่าเอ่อเราทำบุญไปให้
เอ่อคุณปู่คุณคุณย่าใช่มยคุณปู่คุณย่าที่
ตายไปแล้วเราก็หาอาหารที่คุณปู่คุณย่าชอบ
ก็ได้เหมือนกันนะและอาหารที่พระชอบถ้าเรา
ไม่รู้เราถามพระได้มั้ยพระชอบกินอะไรอ๋อ
เอ่อเราถามพระไม่ได้ครับไม่ได้ไม่ต้องถาม
อ่าอ่าไม่ต้องถามพระก็จะไม่บอกนะคะเรา
ต้องใช่ไปทำบุญบ่อยๆแล้วเราก็อ๋อออ่าพระ
ฉันอะไรได้นะคะฉันอะไรไม่ได้อือ่าครั้ง
หน้าเราก็เปลี่ยนอาหารที่พระฉันได้นะคะอื
อือฮึ
อออย่างเงี้ยครูเอ๋ชอบชอบอะไรนะชอบผลไม้
ครูเอ๋ก็เอาผลไม้ไปทำบุญแต่สมมุตินะคุณ
พ่อคุณแม่คุณปู่คุณย่าครูเอ๋น่ะชอบ
ทุเรียนอ๋อชอบทุเรียนก็เอาทุเรียนไปได้
ครับเอ้อเอาทุเรียนไปเอาทุเรียนไปได้ครับ
เอ่อครูเอกยกทุเรียนไปทั้งลูกเลยได้มั้ย
คะอ่ายกทุเรียนไปทั้งลูกไม่ได้ครับไม่ได้
อ่าต้องแกะออกมาเอาแต่เนื้อไปเอาแต่เนื้อ
เอาแต่เนื้อนะไม่ไม่ไม่ยกทุเรียนไปเอ้าก็
ครูเอ๋คิดพระอาจจะไม่ฉันวันนี้ฉันพรุ่ง
นี้ได้มั้ยอ๋อไม่ได้ไม่ได้ครับไม่ได้อือ
พระเก็บอาหารไม่ได้ใช่อ่าไม่เก็บไว้ครับ
เก็บอาหารไว้สำหรับพรุ่งนี้ไม่ได้นะคะอ
งั้นเนี่ยแกะไปเลยนะคะนักเรียนจะให้พระไป
เปิดไปแกะเองเนี่ยไม่ได้อืออทีนี้เรามี
อาหารละอาหารที่จะเอาไปถวายพระเนี่ยก็
ต้องให้พระเนี่ยสามารถตัดแล้วก็ฉันได้
ง่ายๆนะคะอพอไปถึงวัดเทำอะไรต่อคะอ่าไป
ถึงวัดไปถึงวัดเราก็เอาอาหารเนี่ยเนี่ย
เอ่อเอ่อไปถวายพระแต่แต่พระเนี่ยจะเอ่อจะ
ยังไม่ไม่ไม่ลงมารับอาหารจากเราทันทีค่ะ
นะครับเพราะว่าต้องรอให้หลายๆ
คนถวายอาหารให้ให้ครบทุกคนก่อนทุกๆคนถวาย
อาหารให้พระได้หมดก่อนแล้วพระก็จะมารับ
อาหารพร้อมๆกันอืครุอาตี้มีรูปมั้ยคะที่
พระอ่าจะคนอ่าประเคนอาหารน่ะอ๋ออ่านี่
ครับอ่าจะเป็นรูปรูปนี้ครับอ่าเวลาเ่าเรา
ไปทำบุญเราก็เอาอาหารมามาวางไว้ก่อนนะ
ครับพร้อมๆกันทั้งหมดพออาหารมาพร้อมแล้ว
พระมาพร้อมแล้วเราก็ถึงจะเริ่มถวายอาหาร
หรือเรียกว่าที่ครูเอ๋เรียกว่าประเคนใช่
มั้ยคือการยกนะคะอสมมุตินี้เป็นถาดอาหาร
ยกแล้วก็ส่งไปที่พระพระท่านต้องรับนะคะ
อาจจะรับที่มือนิดนึงนะคะหรือยกมาเลยก็
ได้อันนี้ว่าประเคนนะคะใช่อ่าการอ่าให้
อาหารพระเอ่อเอายกอาหารให้พระอ่าเรียกว่า
ประเคนใช่มั้ยครับใช่เอ๊ะผู้หญิงอ่ะผู้
หญิงยกให้กับพระแล้วพระรับเลยได้มั้ยคะ
อ๋อพระไม่สามารถรับรับกับเ่อมือจากมือผู้
หญิงหรือรับโดยตรงจากผู้หญิงไม่ได้ไม่ได้
แบบนี้ไม่ได้นะครับสมมุติว่าสมมติว่าอัน
นี้เป็นอถาดถาดอาหารอ่ะส่งไปตรงนี้มือไ
อยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็มือพระจับตรงเนี้ยได้
มั้ยออ่าไม่ได้ครับไม่ได้ได้อ่าพระต้องมี
ต้องมีอ่ะสมมุติอันนี้นี่ๆๆๆพระท่านจะใช้
แบบนี้ครับท่านจะใช้ผ้าผ้ามารองจะไม่รับ
โดยตรงจากมือถ้ามีผู้หญิงถ้าเป็นผู้หญิง
เป็นคนประเคนพระก็จะใช้ผ้าผ้ารองอีกทีนึง
อือฮึหรือไม่ก็ผ้าวางแล้วก็ให้เราวางบน
ผ้าใช่ได้เหมือนกันได้แล้วพระท่านก็จะยก
มาแต่ถ้าเป็นผู้ชายได้เลยได้เลยใช่ครับ
ไม่ต้องใช้ผ้ารับอือฮึ
อืโอเคก็พระพระมาครบคนไปครบนะคะก็จะถึง
เวลาประเคนอใช่อือฮึอ่าก็เป็นการทำบุญนะ
ครับที่วัดกันนะครับแล้วพระก็จะต้องต้อง
สวดมนต์ก่อนใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ครับก็จะมีการ
สวดนะครับก่อนเอ่อในระหว่างที่เราประเคน
อาหารพระเสร็จแล้วพระก็จะสวดก่อนสวดเสร็จ
พระก็จะฉันนะครับต่างๆค่ะพระก็จะฉันอาหาร
อือฮึเราก็นั่งดูใช่มั้ยคะอ่าเราก็นั่งรอ
ให้พระสวดให้เสร็จนะครับพระสวดเราก็เราก็
นั่งพนมมือแล้วก็ฟังฟังพระที่สวดไปด้วยนะ
ครับอ่านะครับคุยกันได้มั้ยคุยกันเป็นไ
สบายดี
มั้ยส่วนใหญ่ส่วนใหญ่คนจะมีคุยกันแต่ที่
ถูกต้องแล้วไม่ควรจะคุยแล้วควรจะนั่ง
เงียบๆนะครับฟังใช่ฟังพระนะครับอือยกเว้น
เวลาที่พระฉันอาหารอันเนี้ยเราคุยกันได้
ใช่ๆตอนที่อแต่เวลาที่พระสวดนะคะออนเนี้ย
พระกำลังพูดสวดมนต์แล้วบอกสวดมนต์ก็อะไร
นะสวดมนต์เนี่ยเราก็จะต้องฟังบางตอนเรา
อาจจะต้องสวดด้วยใช่ใช่ครับเราก็ต้องพูด
ด้วยเป็นบาลีนะคะ
อโอเคอ่าโอเคนี่ก็เป็นการไปทำบุญที่วัด
ใช่ครับแล้วเดี๋ยวอ่าเดี๋ยวเ่อคราวหน้า
เรากลับมาติดตามกันต่อว่ามีวันนี้การทำ
บุญแบบที่ 1 ที่เราคุยกันในวันนี้คือการ
ไปทำบุญที่วัดใช่มั้ยใช่เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าห
มีทั้งที่มีอาหารไปหรือถวายปัจจัยก็ได้อ
อ่าได้ทั้งคู่นะครับอือฮึอ่าเดี๋ยวคลิป
หน้าเราจะมาคุยกันเรื่องการทำบุญอีกนะ
ครับแต่ว่าคราวนี้เนี่ยเราจะไม่ได้ไปที่
วัดและอ๋อเราไปที่ไหนอใช่อ่ะมีอีกทีหนึ่ง
ที่นักเรียนน่าจะเคยเห็นถ้าเคยมาประเทศ
ไทยก็จะเคยเห็นว่าเอ๊ะเราก็เห็นเคยเห็นคน
ทำบุญไม่ได้ทำที่วัดด้วยเหมือนกันเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้าเราจะมาคุยกันนะครับอืโอเคค่ะ
สำหรับวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้ว
ครับครับเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คลิป
หน้าครับวันนี้เรา 2 คนลาไปก่อนแล้วครับ
ค่ะสวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีครับ
นักเรียสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย